Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, je vous embarque
dans le triangle des Bermudes.
Il s'y passe
des choses bizarres.
Depuis 1945, une centaine de bateaux et une vingtaine d'avions s'y sont volatilisés.
Alors certains y voient l'ombre
des extraterrestres.
D'autres évoquent
des phénomènes paranormaux.
Enfilez votre gilet de sauvetage.
Et j'ai peut être une explication
à vous donner.
5 décembre 1945.
L'escadrille numéro 19, composée de cinq
avions bombardiers, décolle
de la base de Fort Lauderdale en Floride,
pour un simple entraînement.
La routine.
À sa tête, le lieutenant instructeur
Charles Taylor, 28 ans, un pilote aguerri.
Il est accompagné de quatorze
jeunes pilotes, tous en formation.
Le vol s'annonce bien.
Ce jour là, la météo est clémente
et l'humeur des troupes est au beau fixe.
Mais très vite, le temps se gâte
au dessus de l'Atlantique.
L'escadrille est prise dans un tourbillon
que l'on n'avait pas vu venir.
Des vents violents suivis
d'un gros orage s'abattent sur les avions.
Les compas, ces instruments de navigation que l'on utilise pour se localiser,
s'affolent et finissent par tomber en panne.
Au bout de quelques minutes,
la base de Fort Lauderdale
perd le contrôle radar avec les équipages.
Dans son dernier message radio,
le lieutenant Taylor lance complètement affolé :
"On dirait qu'on rentre dans les eaux troubles."
"Nous sommes complètement perdus."
L'US Navy dépêche aussitôt
deux hydravions de secours.
Mais là encore, l'expédition
vire au cauchemar.
Un seul engin rentre à la base et l'autre
explose en vol.
Il fait nuit sur l'Atlantique et plus aucune nouvelle de l'escadrille numéro 19.
Durant des semaines,
des dizaines d'hommes
et d'avions sont envoyés sur place
à la recherche d'indices.
Des cinq avions bombardiers
et de l'hydravion, on ne retrouve rien.
Pas un corps, pas un débris.
Le bilan est lourd 27 personnes
sont déclarées officiellement disparues.
L'événement fait la une des journaux
avec une question qui revient
sans cesse :
"Où est passée l'escadrille numéro 19 ?"
l'Armée est incapable de donner la moindre explication.
L'enquête officielle
se contente de pointer la responsabilité
de Charles Taylor, qui n'aurait pas su
prendre les bonnes décisions.
Puis le temps passe
et cette sombre histoire tombe
dans les oubliettes.
Jusqu'en 1964,
où Vincent Gaddis, un journaliste américain, relance l'affaire.
Intrigué par le sort
des militaires et de leurs avions,
il mène sa propre enquête.
Et, à sa grande surprise, il ne tarde pas
à découvrir que l'escadrille numéro 19
est loin d'être la seule à s'être
volatilisée dans ce secteur.
Ce secteur, le voici.
Il s'agit d'une zone qui relie l'archipel
des Bermudes, Miami et Porto Rico.
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
elle forme un triangle.
Du navire à vapeur américain SS Cotopaxi qui sombre corps et biens en 1925
à la destruction en vol d'une
vingtaine d'appareils.
Plus de 100 disparitions dans les airs
et en mer
ont eu lieu à l'intérieur
de cette zone géographique en un siècle.
Christophe Colomb lui même
avait signalé dans son journal de bord
le comportement anormal de ses boussoles à cet endroit.
Pour Vincent Gaddis,
ce n'est pas le fruit du hasard.
Il pense que ce triangle d'environ
1 million de kilomètres carrés, deux fois
la France, est très dangereux
pour toute personne qui s'y aventure.
Et il lui donne un nom
le triangle des Bermudes.
C'est le point de départ d'une
des plus grandes énigmes du XXᵉ siècle.
Elle va alimenter tous les fantasmes.
Ces mystérieuses disparitions intriguent en particulier Charles Berlitz,
un écrivain américain à succès,
passionné de phénomènes paranormaux.
En 1974, il publie The Bermuda Triangle.
Je ne traduit pas.
Il s'agit d'un ouvrage qui recueille les témoignages de personnes
ayant survécu à des catastrophes
à l'intérieur de la zone.
Sur la base de ces témoignages.
L'écrivain élabore une théorie.
Ce phénomène serait lié à la présence
d'une pyramide de pierre engloutie
dans les profondeurs du triangle.
Il s'agirait des vestiges
d'une civilisation vieille de 12000 ans.
L'édifice exercerait une attraction
sur les avions et les navires.
La thèse séduit un Français,
le célèbre apnéiste Jacques Mayol.
Vous savez, c'est celui dont l'histoire
est racontée dans le film Le Grand Bleu.
Du coup, Jacques Mayol décide
de se rendre sur place
pour vérifier la théorie de Berlitz.
Il plonge.
Malheureusement, il rentre bredouille.
D'autres avancent des hypothèses
encore plus loufoques,
comme la présence d'une porte sous marine ouverte sur une autre dimension,
ou bien,
l'existence d'un monstre géant capable
d'aspirer les navires au fond de l'océan.
Enfin, la thèse la plus farfelue
est toujours très populaire aujourd'hui.
Ces disparitions seraient dues
à des extraterrestres vivant
dans les profondeurs.
Mais vous l'avez
compris, tout au long des années
70, 80, l'ouvrage provoque
une véritable fascination
autour du triangle des Bermudes,
qu'on ne tarde pas à rebaptiser
le triangle du diable
ou encore le triangle maudit.
A la même époque, cependant,
le gouvernement américain tente de calmer les esprits.
Au milieu des années 70,
on envoie sur place
une commission d'enquête pour étudier
les causes des différentes disparitions.
La conclusion est sans appel
chaque volatilisation,
ce sont les termes de l'armée, serait due soit à la météo,
soit à des problèmes techniques à bord
des avions.
Bref, il n'y aurait aucun mystère
autour du triangle des Bermudes.
Côté météo,
on incrimine les cyclones tropicaux.
Ils sévissent dans la région de juin
à novembre
et suivent un trajet bien précis
au dessus de l'océan Atlantique.
Les scientifiques
l'appellent l'allée des ouragans.
Eh bien, il se trouve
que le triangle se situe en plein milieu.
Lorsqu'ils arrivent à sa hauteur,
leur force est terrifiante.
L'œil du cyclone peut atteindre
plus de 1000 kilomètres de diamètre
et les vents dépassent parfois
250 kilomètres par heure.
Mais ceci ne peut pas expliquer
la disparition de l'escadrille numéro 19.
Souvenez vous, elle s'est volatilisée
au mois de décembre 1945, en plein hiver.
Alors, les météorologues avancent
une autre hypothèse.
La saison froide,
qui s'étend de décembre à mai, produit
elle aussi son lot de perturbations,
bien moins prévisibles.
On les surnomme les bombes.
Ce sont des tempêtes
brèves et ultraviolentes qui se déclenchent
d'un instant à l'autre dans un ciel qui,
jusque là, était d'un bleu azur.
C'est peut être l'une d'entre elles
qui aurait englouti les avions
et leurs équipages le 5 décembre 1945.
À l'origine de ce piège, le Gulf Stream.
Ce courant chaud bien connu
traverse le triangle des Bermudes.
Le contraste entre ce courant chaud,
les eaux de l'océan froides et les masses
d'air tout aussi fraîches pendant l'hiver,
forment un cocktail explosif
qui engendre des vents très violents
et des pluies torrentielles.
C'est aussi à lui que l'on attribue
la formation de vagues immenses
que l'on appelle les vagues scélérates.
Elles grimpent jusqu'à 30 mètres de hauteur et pourraient
être responsables du naufrage
de nombreux navires.
Mais, aussi séduisantes
soient elles, ces différentes hypothèses
ne font pas l'unanimité
dans la communauté scientifique.
Alors, on continue de chercher
de nouvelles explications.
Et si la cause de ces mystérieuses
disparitions
était tout simplement
d'origine magnétique ?
C'est l'avis de certains scientifiques
qui soulignent
qu'à l'intérieur du triangle,
les boussoles se mettent parfois
à tourner sans raison,
au point de désorienter les marins.
En suivant cette piste, ils finissent
par identifier un responsable.
La roche volcanique gorgée de magnétite qui s'étale sur plus
de 200 kilomètres
sous le plancher océanique à cet endroit.
La plus grande concentration de magnétite
se trouve dans la zone du triangle.
Cette nouvelle hypothèse pourrait
expliquer le naufrage des bateaux,
mais aussi les pannes qui surviennent sur les instruments de bord dans les avions.
Mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là.
En 2015,
une nouvelle explication voit le jour.
Le coupable serait le méthane.
D'importantes poches de ce gaz
se trouvent dans le
sous-sol, à l'aplomb du triangle.
Suite à des mouvements de terrain,
le gaz serait libéré
et remonterait à la surface
jusque dans l'atmosphère.
Intoxiquant au passage, les pilotes
des avions naviguant dans la zone.
La présence de ce gaz modifie
également la densité de l'eau.
Les navires ne peuvent plus
flotter dessus.
Ils coulent.
Tous ceux qui ont disparu auraient
donc été entraînés par le fond.
Voilà, où nous en sommes aujourd'hui.
Alors, les savants ont-ils définitivement percé le mystère ?
Pas sûr, car cette hypothèse
ne convainc pas tout le monde.
Le redoutable triangle des Bermudes n'a
sans doute pas encore livré
tous ses secrets.
J'aime bien l'aventure, mais pas sûr que
j'aille y passer des vacances.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à liker
et à vous abonner.
Et si vous aimez ce genre d'histoires,
dites-le moi en commentaire.
J'en ai plein les tiroirs.
À très bientôt.
Les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.